les baleines séjournent dans le
saint-laurent depuis la nuit des temps
pourtant on sait peu de choses sur les
endroits précis fréquentés par ces
géants vulnérables tout au long de
l'année or si on veut protéger les
baleines il faut savoir où elles vont et
justement des scientifiques commencent à
percer certains des mystères de leur
terrain de jeu
[Musique]
fin octobre la météo est incertaine sur
le fleuve saint laurent au large de
rimouski
est-ce que tu as entendu comme dernières
nouvelles il y avait encore des animaux
au niveau du trou arcamone ce matin une
équipe de pêches et océans canada
remonte le courant en direction de
tadoussac ces scientifiques ont une
mission bien précise à réaliser alors
aujourd'hui ce qu'on essaie de faire
c'est de trop d'erreurs call commun pour
déployer des émetteurs sept élèves sur
leur dos avant qu'ils partent sur leur
migration saisonnière possible et suis
fait comprendre au west qui vont lorsque
sont pas ici
au loin on aperçoit un premier souffle
de baleines à 11 ans à peu près j'ai eu
un beau dos avec une belle grosse
dorsale qui ressent un commun mais est
ce bien un rorqual commun
c'est triste une année un peu
particulière parce que beaucoup de
baleines à bosse dans l'estuaire ici
donc on cherche du rorqual commun à
travers beaucoup beaucoup de baleines à
bosse
puis d'autres plus confirmés quelque
chose à christophe lebon ce
qu'on continue à avancer
peu à peu le temps deviennent plus
clément tout le monde est aux aguets ok
je pense que je n'aurai commun
chacun a un rôle bien précis à jouer on
va mettre un émetteur sur une flèche qui
ont inséré dans un fusil à air comprimé
qui nous permet de déployer à distance
ces balises le son tout petit
[Musique]
une fois qu'on est près des animaux on
étudie un petit peu leur patron le
déplacement on se prépare
on va s'approcher très près de ses
moulures
idéalement maximum 7 m encore loin
christian
trop loin ce qu'on vise c'est la
nageoire dorsale qui as est grosse mais
c'est une petite ville qui bouge dans un
bateau qui bouge avec ce n'est pas
toujours facile non plus on les installe
dans la longeur dorsale parce que c'est
souvent le morceau de la baleine qui va
sortir le plus souvent puis aussi c'est
assez fibreuse qui fait que ça va nous
aider à faire en sorte que les balises
vont rester le plus longtemps possible
sur les animaux
pas de chance la baleine a déjà une
balise on doit tout recommencer
le rorqual commun ne passe pas incognito
c'est le deuxième plus grand animal de
la planète après le rorqual bleu il peut
mesurer entre 18 et 24 mètres et peser
de 40 à 50 tonnes
malgré sa dimension le rorqual commun
est considéré comme le plus rapide des
grands cétacés
on le surnomme le lévrier des mères
ils ont vraiment fait pour aller dans
l'autre épreuve et sans
beaucoup de
l'énergie
au sprint sept baleines peut atteindre
des vitesses de 30 à 40 km heure et
parcourir des distances considérables en
une journée en théorie peut se déplacer
qu'en parce que 500 km extrême normal
c'est comme un disque remettre leur mais
c'est quand même bon 24 heures c'est une
240 km ce géant a une espérance de vie
de 80 à 100 ans
mais c'est aussi un géant fragile la
population de rorqual commun du ca laura
est composé de 300 à 350 individus mais
elle stagne depuis dix ans l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature considère qu'il s'agit d'une
espèce vulnérable
lors cm en est on veut protéger l'espèce
veut protéger les habitations aux 3 6
ans
il faut commencer quelque part donc donc
c'est ce qu'on est cette femme
les mammifères marins sont confrontés à
différentes menaces ici comme ailleurs
sur la planète
par exemple l'encadrement dans des
engins de pêche est une cause importante
de mortalité pour les baleines
c'est le triste sort qui est arrivé à
capitaine crochet un rorqual commun bien
connu dans la région de tadoussac
il y a aussi les collisions avec les
bateaux qui sont souvent fatales en 2017
dans ce secteur largement fréquenté par
les baleines on a enregistré plus de
4500 transit de navires marchands
on voit à l'écran vers un petit port
tout c'est une envie comme safran +
molène ça c'est la fin des malades c'est
le bateau guide a gagné
depuis 2014 beau temps mauvais temps
l'équipe de scientifiques multiplie les
sorties sur le fleuve à la recherche d
rorqual commun
en tout ils ont fixé une trentaine de
balises qui sont restés accrochés en
moyenne 32 jours aux baleines ces
émetteurs ont fourni des données
précieuses sur leurs déplacements
mais les émetteurs sur les animaux peu
après en sortant de chez nous on prend
le petit café on prend notre ordinateur
pour payer suivre pour les restes des de
l'otan à partir de notre ordinateur puis
on va nous dire où est ce qu'elle est
rendue
près du phare de pointe au père à
rimouski yvan simard c'est pourquoi le
secteur en face de lui est propice à la
pose de balises le scientifique a
consacré sa carrière à comprendre ce qui
pousse tant de mammifères marins à venir
s'alimenter de mai à novembre dans le
golfe et l'estuaire du saint laurent
ce qui explique la présence de madame
fut loin par rapport à l'atlantic effet
jusqu'à tadoussac fait une grande marche
alors
c'est par ce chenal long de 1000
kilomètres que l'eau salée de l'océan
pénètre à l'intérieur du fleuve le krill
un plancton dont se nourrissent les
baleines suit cette masse d'eau à la
hauteur de tadoussac la profondeur du
fleuve passe subitement de 350 m à 20
mètres sur le seuil du saguenay c'est un
mur qui ai rencontrés et ça crée des
processus osama graphiques complexes des
remontées d'eaux profondes
et puis ça importe en même temps le
planton acquis forme d agrégation dans
cette région là
et dalhem peuvent pas s'alimenter si on
prenait la même quantité maintenant
quand la répartie surtout blog sonnera
faut que je sois concentré
on nous montrait que c'est un site où la
richesse entre entités de crise est
comparable aux sites les plus importants
des choses de crédit au monde
[Musique]
c'est au milieu de ce set exceptionnel
que l'équipe de véronique lesage temps
d'installer les balises
celle posée l'année dernière ont permis
de constater que l'erreur call commun ce
sont alimentés presque exclusivement à
un seul endroit dans le saint laurent
ici au large de tadoussac dans un petit
secteur nommé le trou à commun ce qui
était très très particulier puis même
inquiétant l'an dernier puis qui pour
moi mais un gros drapeau rouge dans les
airs c'est que le trou a connu l'an
dernier c'était le seul endroit où on
trouvait des rorqual commun
donc si on perturbe cet environnement le
fait que les animaux peuvent fusillade
parce que c'est ça devient tolérable et
on pas d'alternative
mais en 2020 la grande surprise est
venue de deux heures cale commun
un d'eux se nomme tic roche c'est leur
rejeton de capitaine crochet leur
périple accueilli les chercheurs en
haleine
meetic roche je dirais que c'est
l'exemple de la balise de rêve
c'est-à-dire qu'on la dévoyer le la
balise et l'animal est partie et nous en
a pris énormément sur la population
que tu craches au fait est ce que il est
parti du site et à les virer bien au sud
de la distribution connu de l'espèce
donc être libéré dans le coin des
bahamas est allé se promener le long
dacoda floride un autre ami dans les
talus le long des côtes de floride c'est
la première fois qu'on suivait des
rorqual commun aussi longtemps durant
l'automne et l'hiver quand ces animaux
le sens sortie du golfe moi c'est la
première chose que je fais en me levant
le matin que la dernière que je faisais
ma bouche et soudée regardez qu'est ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
avec de jour en jour c'est des
kilomètres des kilomètres que l'animal
avait parcouru pleure sur westside
on connaît peu de choses sur les aires
d'hivernage des rorqual commun qui
s'alimentent dans le saint laurent
on sait qu'avec l'arrivée des glaces
c'est rorqual menhir pour aller se
reproduire soit ils restent dans le
golfe où se dirige vers le plateau néo
écossais où ils vont passer la saison
froide mais la balise fixé à tiques
roche a tout remis en question
pour voir ce qu'on pensait qu'ils
étaient là la façon de déplacer les
mouvements la structure des stocks pour
cette population lefa club et tout le
monde me retourne à son tableau puis ont
commencé à réfléchir
vous vous demandez peut-être ou éthique
roche aujourd'hui sa balise à
fonctionner plus longtemps que la
moyenne du 5 octobre 2020 au 12 janvier
2021 avant de cesser d'émettre et bien
bonne nouvelle si cross était de retour
dans l'estuaire du saint laurent avec
l'arrivée du beau temps
c'est en observant certains signes
distinctifs que les chercheurs ont
réussi à identifier cette baleine dont
on ne sait toujours pas s'il s'agit d'un
mâle ou d'une femelle
d'autres vocal commun vont maintenant
prendre la relève de tic roche avec une
nouvelle génération de balises elles
permettront de les localiser avec plus
de précision et aussi de fournir des
données détaillées sur la profondeur et
la durée des plongées
on pourra ainsi
estimé le temps que les baleines passe
près de la surface et donc les risques
de collision
la mission est importante comme le
terrain je dévore call commun du
saint-laurent semble beaucoup plus vaste
qu on l'avait imaginé des efforts
concertés entre les pays seront donc
nécessaires pour assurer leur protection
que je trouve vos servir année
gestionnaire qui vont prendre les
décisions pour protéger des espèces
[Musique]
oui
from top nous on apporte la séance on
donne des avis notre séance nourrissent
des 6es au losc pour nous aucune épreuve
non mais
ça peut aider à conserver les espèces
rousseau et c'est une belle histoire à
raconter à thézan jetons
[Musique]